on today's show we're going to talk to a
young mom
who's still getting over her husband's
affair several years ago even after she
said i forgive you
we're going to talk through what she can
do next we're going to talk to a mom
who's struggling with a child with
behavior disorder
and a husband who just doesn't get it
and we're going to talk to a young man
in texas
who sets me up with the following
question my girlfriend's gained weight
what do i do oh boy stay tuned
yo yo this is john and this is the dr
john deloney show
it's a live show where we take real
calls from real people
trying to figure out what to do next
trying to figure out how to love how to
forgive
how to walk through these crazy times
how to help pick each other up when we
fall
we're going to talk about marriage we're
going to talk about parenting
relationships love loss and fidelity all
of it and i want to do a special shout
out
for moms it's not mother's day it's not
anything special
but moms across the country are burying
the brunt of all of this mess the
madness
the homeschooling the working from home
and i know there's great dads out there
too don't send me your mean cards and
letters but
i just want to take a moment shout out
moms i get emails
all the time get phone calls all the
time from moms
just saying what do i do how do i love
my kid better
my husband's been furloughed how do i
help pick him up at the same time how do
i help take care of this home
how do i figure out what day it is even
right
and i'm watching my wife who is just an
absolute rock star
absolute ninja i'm watching her just try
to figure it out
and some days are hard some days are
just hard
right i got an email here from tanya
tanya writes dr john
recently i heard you say you're a mom
and moms are allowed to be selfish
that ring so true in my soul after 16
years of trying to give my three boys
the best but why is that okay
i'm thinking you don't mean selfish in
the traditional sense of the word but
rather
because moms often times are not selfish
but just
feel that way can you please explain
what you meant by that comment
tanya what a gift thanks for that note
here's what i meant by that
i don't think anybody should be selfish
i think everybody should wake up every
day with
one goal and that is to try to serve the
people closest to them
and if everybody started their day that
way
what a different world we'd live in
right but here's the thing
moms are also women
and women are socialized to be
peacekeepers
to make sure everybody else is okay
to make sure their precious husbands
are doing okay to make sure their dads
and moms are doing okay to make sure all
the plans are made now i know
i'm speaking in gross generalities and
so if you're some
wonderful husband who's mowing the yard
right now chill out relax
take a breather but on the whole
moms are trained from the time they are
little girls to make sure everybody else
is okay
and then you throw in kids you throw in
a full-time job
you throw in a household where the
research tells us
guys we think we're helping 50-50 but
we're not
it's 90 10 it's 80 20. a really great
house is 70 30.
and you've got moms pulling way more
than their share
and we got dual incomes and and and
and so when i use a word like selfish
saying moms it's okay to be selfish
what i'm really saying is moms it's okay
to speak up and allow yourself to be
loved and care for it
it's okay moms to just occasionally
turn a movie on and just go sit outside
and stare off into space
it's okay if you guys have budgeted for
it and you can afford it
to go get your take care of yourself
whatever if that's a massage if that's
whatever that looks like for you if
that's yoga classes
it's okay to ask your husband to pick up
some slack
and to be specific here's the things i
need some help with
it's okay to tell your kids not right
now
it's okay to just
exhale to just be whole
moms it's okay to get a full night of
sleep and to build your world
backwards to reverse engineer your world
outside of a good night's sleep
and husbands it's okay to sit down with
your wives
and say how do i help you
become more whole how do i i need some
specifics here because
this i'm this is new and i'm trying to
be vulnerable and i'm trying to learn
some new tools
but what can i do what can i do to help
balance this home
to do my part how can i pick up some
slack
how can i come home from work
take a breath and lean back in
how can i help with bedtime with bath
times whatever that may look like
but moms just want to shout you out
right now 2020 has been hard
hard hard it's been hard on everybody
from children
to grown-ups to elderly folks to the
well to the sick it's been
it's been troubling for everybody but
moms y'all are caring a lot
and i just want to say thank you and so
while i don't mean
wake up and just start being selfish i
do mean
paint a picture co-paint a picture with
your husband if you've got one who's
great and who will sit with you
paint a picture of a world where you're
well and whole and the things
that you need to be well and whole
you're able to do
and reverse engineer what that world is
going to look like and it may mean one
less practice
it may mean one less family event it may
mean your husband cooks one more meal
or it may mean your husband learns how
to do laundry on the weekends whatever
that looks like
but i just want to shout you out moms
you know doing hard heroes work these
days
so i didn't mean to get sidetracked that
way but whatever's going on in your
heart and home or head i'm here to stand
with you
moms dads kids grandparents everybody
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com show
to the show page send me your questions
from there
and i can't wait to check them out all
right let's go straight to the phone
here let's go
to let's see here let's go to stephanie
in tuscaloosa
stephanie what's going on hello john
thank you for taking my call
thank you so much for calling in how can
i help um
i have a 11 year old
who was diagnosed in the third grade
with adhd and odd
he was actually hospitalized in a
children's psych ward for a couple weeks
due to extreme
uh aggression and violence um
my husband who also has um
depression and anxiety and all that kind
of thing i can't get him to understand
that my 11 year old this is his normal
he will never be a typical
11 year old you know he has ticks and
how do i get
my husband to accept that that's just
how he is
oh there's a lot here stephanie
one um before we move on i was just
talking about moms here
i would love for you just to exhale real
big and drop your shoulders down for a
second
okay and i just want to say thank you i
know what you're going through the lot
and from start to finish here so
walk me back let's start with your
husband you say he's diagnosed with
anxiety depression
what is what's the trajectory of that
how long has he had that and what is
that
what does that actually look like how
does that manifest in your house
um well he
he's had it his whole life he's got
anger management issues
from forever which is part of his
issue with my son is he sees himself in
my son
um because he had um
you know he was in remedial classes and
special education and stuff as a kid
because of
behavior and anger and things like that
what was his family
what was his family life like um
he's from uh i guess she said a broken
home his parents divorced when he was
like two but his stepdad's been in the
picture since he was five
um but you know they moved around a lot
it was very
um difficult you know
lower income kind of situation for him
okay so we're talking about
the the forest fire of trauma burning
through now
one generation to the next and now it's
being passed on to a third
right yeah um so
when your husband has anger issues when
he goes off into
a rage just give me an example paint me
a picture of what that looks like
um there's just a lot of yelling okay um
you know and he he blames everyone of
course else you know
you know nothing ever happens to him
it's always something else's fault
um but you know it's always
uh he he has a he has a habit of
bringing up the past
you know he can't just let stuff go
right
so when did your son start exhibiting
signs to when did you start recognizing
just as his mom
well let me back up does he have
brothers or sisters or do you just have
one kid
he does he has um two older siblings
okay a sister and a brother
and how are they um
i mean for them i'd say they're normal
there's no such thing as normal but
right they don't have any
they don't have any of these issues um
is one of them it's just the youngest
does one of them
excel in grades or excel in sports
or excel in 4-h or some sort of program
no not really they're just average kids
plugging along
okay how old are they uh well the sister
is 21
okay and the brother is almost 14.
no no drugs no addictions no eating
disorders nothing like that
no okay and so then
along comes this little one was he
planned
or was he just a gift uh
well he was a year early but yes
we had planned on having another but he
was a surprise okay
okay um so you plan on having another is
the 21 year old is she your biological
kid too
she is not i married um her dad when she
was four
okay okay
okay so there's a lot here so yes
i've got some very specific thoughts
about
oppositional defined disorder and
i'm interested to know what happened
what cis
take me back a week before your kid was
hospitalized up until the actual
hospitalization what happened
um he was suspended from the third time
from his regular home school
due to uh what they call
non-compliance he didn't want to do what
the teacher told him to do okay
things like that um so he was suspended
for the third time
which had him go to the alternative
school
he goes to public school okay and the
alternative school
um he didn't
fit there either he didn't he doesn't
like to be told what to do
what happens what happens at home when
he's told something he doesn't want to
do
um
if he's not on his medicine he can have
extreme outbursts
um he you know he'll throw things he'll
he'll scream you know just
take your picture like a two or three
year old toddler only
at seven or eight years old how long has
he done that
uh since he was two or three um when
when he was toddling around the house
you know you would tell him no when he
would just go to like slam his head into
the wall and things like that
okay um but it's at some point that
at some point that and of course there's
genetic components to this and there's
biological components of that
but at some point that sort of
outburst he either saw it
or he understood that at some shape form
or fashion to work for him
oh yeah oh he works the system like
nobody's business
he picks up real quick on what gets him
the attention that he wants
and so there are circumstances because
one of the hallmarks of
odd is do they have outburst in one
place or in two place or in multiple
places
and that lends me to believe that when
they need to
young children can often control it
there is a moment when a kid
gets past their ability to control
themselves they've completely spun out
right
but up until then they usually have a
pretty good sense of what works where
and who they can push when and what is
that right
yes and once the adults in their life
stop acting like adults meaning he's
able to push his dad far enough to where
his dad will just start slamming stuff
and he'll get the attention and the
interaction that he's desperately
craving
or he may push you to a point that's
what i'm trying to get at so
what he he's in a school
and somebody tells him something he
don't want to do he knows i can control
this whole classroom by setting it off
and then he gets removed and sent to
another place where they
punish children by disconnecting them
from everything
and i have a whole other thing about
about alternative schools he gets sent
there and
obviously unwinds and then what does he
ultimately do that gets him
put into a psych ward for a few weeks um
he was attacking the resource officers
okay
he just at that point he just lost every
day like he just he would completely
lose it
okay all right and what is something
that you know of besides medication
what is something that you know of that
brings him down
that gives him peace in his own skin
music okay
um he likes he likes to listen to music
um and honestly he just he likes to be
alone
and quiet okay does he have any sort of
does he have any relationships whether
it's with you
with his siblings with a pet with his
dad does he have any sort of
relationships that bring him peace
um he yeah we have three dogs and he
loves to snuggle with the dogs
okay um and what
what's amusing is my husband actually
has a better relationship
with him than i do because he can get
down on his level and talk to him
and calm him down whereas when i talk to
him it just spirals him up worse usually
why is that i don't know um
probably because my husband is always
telling him you know i was like you
i know where you're coming from i've had
these you know issues
um and so he relates more to my husband
than he does to me because i don't
i've never had those issues and i you
know my
childhood was completely different than
than my husband's
okay so we could talk on this particular
issue for a long time
and that's not particularly why you
called um
i this doesn't solve everything and this
won't quote unquote solve this
issue okay but i and this isn't why you
called so this is just bonus stuff
but if at all possible
i would love for you to
spend some time regularly as in
every day if not twice a day
holding your son and tell him
like one thing i mommy really likes to
do is
hug her baby boy and i want you to touch
your face to his face and just hold him
for a minute and he may push you away
and if he does that's so so be it he
needs to learn autonomy with his body
but i want you to be the grown up
however painful that is because and that
constant rejection sucks i get that
but i want you to do the best you can
outside of when he is spun out
to teach him to show him
peace through relationship peace through
connection
and that may be for a while
having him color in a coloring book with
you and y'all just listen to music and
you both color
that may be asking if he wants to watch
a show but you're going to hold his hand
while you watch the show
and you may already do these things my
guess is probably not
and that's not a knock on you kids with
odd
who are violent are scary and especially
if you're a mom and dad and you don't
know what's
going on and watching your kid get wild
eyes is terrifying
but i want you to begin to lean into
that relationship and it's going to be
painful
but i want him over time to equate you
with not
information not you should be and i want
you to
but i want him to equate you with peace
and equate you with safe
and that's going to take a long long
time and like i said it's not going to
just
snap your fingers and suddenly hey we're
off the meds and everything's great
you've got years of trauma here with him
but i want you to lean into that if your
husband was in a place
it would be a gift from heaven if your
husband would also
lean into
human touch and not more advice but lean
into that connection because my guess is
when he gets down on the floor and he's
talking to your son when your son's
hurting it's less about what he's saying
and that he's saying it that he's down
on his level that he's looking him in
the eye that he's saying hey i hear you
and i see you and i've been there
and there's something to all of us
children grown-ups old people
that just that idea of connection that
sense of we are feeling somebody truly
see us
then our alarms can quit setting off but
that's not why you call that's just a
freebie so back to your husband
here's the challenge you're gonna have
with your husband is your husband's not
well
and it doesn't sound like your husband's
um in the business of wanting to get
well
it sounds like he has made peace with
the fact that i just this is the way i
am i'm anxious and i'm depressed and i
had this childhood and so i've got this
adulthood
and i may take meds on or off
but this is kind of way this is and i'm
sick of having a weird kid is that fair
or am i off there
uh very very close okay
okay so when you're talking to somebody
who's not
well like your husband
information doesn't process the way it
does for someone who is well
that insight doesn't come in there so
you may give facts and say hey this is
our little boy and we love him
and he's unique and he's different he's
got challenges
by the way challenges which i think can
be
completely healed if not a long way
towards healing
through renewed relationships so you
really want to
lean in on your son then you and your
husband go to marriage counseling
really work together to have a peaceful
collaborative co-created relationship
together
and that's really hard to do with
someone who's just accepted the fact
that they're not well and that's just
the way that's going to be
and so what you find yourself in is the
unenviable position of
you've got to love that boy the best
that you know how and if you see your
husband be violent if you see your
husband be
um be traumatic and trauma can be both
at right or withholding then you've got
to fill that gap and if there's ever a
moment when your son's not safe
obviously you got to call the police if
your husband's rage and he's smashing
stuff and yelling stuff
i need you to understand the damage
that's doing to your kid
and if you got to call the police you
got to call the police but at this point
you're protecting your son's heart and
mind
and if your husband's mental health
challenges
that he's choosing to not address
are simply taking him away from your son
that's hurting him too
albeit a slower that's a slow burn on
that deal
but the reality is
there's not a thing you're just going to
be able to sit down and tell your
husband
except for maybe this you can try this
one this just
popped into my head you could tell your
husband hey you know how you hurt right
now
you know how people don't treat you
right
and how you're anxious and how you are
exhausted and how there's weeks where
you just don't want to get out of bed
there is healing for our little boy
and you may not care about yourself
enough to get well and that's your
choice you're a grown man
but let's really work hard together
so our son doesn't have to just go
through life like you've had to go
through
love him enough so let's begin to make
these changes
your very first question to me was
how do i tell him that he's just going
to be different
and what i want to tell you is don't
give up on your son
you've seen some scary things that moms
shouldn't have to see
they shouldn't have to see their sons in
handcuffs they shouldn't have to see
their eight-year-olds banging their head
up against the wall and screaming
obscenities and kicking and biting
those things are traumatic they're hard
but i don't want you to give up on your
son and you're going to have to work
with doctors
you're going to have to work with a
relationship coach you are probably
going to have to go see somebody for
yourself
you're in a hard situation and you're
going to have to get with somebody who's
going to help you become whole
so that you can become a peaceful
moment of exhale for your son
and you're gonna have to work towards
nutritional support and sleep support
and high high interactive human touch
laying down on the floor you and your
husband have to decide we're not going
to be on our devices we're going to be
on
our stomachs coloring on the floor with
our son we're going to play legos
together even if we don't talk for 30
minutes or an hour
we're gonna listen to music and just be
with one another and this is going to be
a total shift in your home
but i don't want you to give up on that
little boy
i'm telling you right now there's
healing to be had if y'all will plug in
directly with him and this is a long
game it's a long haul
and it may mean finding different
educational solutions it may mean
all sorts of things and those things
cost money and those things are
exhausting i know
but this is your little boy this is your
little boy
and do not hesitate to call the police
whether if it's your husband or anybody
else
put your son in jeopardy we'll be
thinking about you stephanie this is a
hard road to hoe here
to all parents out there struggling when
they look at their kid and they're just
heartbroken and hurt
lean into those relationships lean in
and i know it's so hard and it just
sounds so trite
and empty and hollow my kid doesn't want
me to hug him i get that
my kid won't sit by me when i want to
just color i get that
keep showing up keep showing up you're
the adult
keep showing up and if it hurts too bad
for you to keep showing up if the
rejection hurts too much
then you have a job to do and that's to
go see somebody
don't outsource your feelings and you're
hurting your pain to your kid
even when they're struggling hard even
when they say ugly awful things to you
don't give them that give them safety
and give them peace
thank you so much for that call
stephanie all right let's go to charlie
in knoxville tennessee
charlie how are we doing i am doing all
right how are you today
all right all right so how can i help
so i am trying to figure out how i can
get
on the same emotional level in my
relationship
as my husband is currently uh oh does
that mean you're gonna
you're gonna go up or gonna go down up
okay tell me about it so our
we've been married for about eight and a
half years okay
we had a really rough couple years
about three almost four years ago okay
some infidelity and we almost got
divorced and
things were just really terrible for
about a year and a half
when you say really rough time and some
infidelity you're speaking very vague so
did you cheat on him did he cheat on you
did you all both cheat on each other
what was the situation so my husband
had an affair okay for about six months
okay
and then he told me about it and then
for the following
year was kind of just this emotional
rollercoaster of us
trying to fix it and then him saying no
i want to be with this other girl and
okay let's try and fix it again no i
still want to be with her
okay and um that went
all the way up for about a year we had
the divorce papers filed we were just
about divorced
and then he was getting into graduate
school out here in tennessee and we were
getting ready to move
and right before it was like two weeks
before we moved she was like no
i really do want to try in our
relationship i've cut things off with
her
i'm completely committed to our marriage
and
then we started our marriage out here
okay so take me back to that one moment
why did you choose to stay with him
um i had chosen to stay with him the
whole time just
partly because i knew that if he would
come back to how he used to be that we
would be
really good together we had always been
really good together we'd always been
really good
friends and i mean he had
before all that he had been you know the
love of my life and everything that i
had wanted and
he was such a good dad and and partner
and i knew that we could get that back
if he
committed back to the relationship and i
didn't want to let that go
so he
he has recommitted am i right
yes but it's not the way things were is
that right
well that's the thing is he
our relationship is better now than it
was before before all of that happened
even at the beginning of our marriage in
a lot of ways our
marriage is a lot better than it ever
was okay um
he really when he committed he 100
committed and he
i mean i went through a lot of therapy
to kind of help myself heal
and work through things and he uh
i mean just put a lot of effort into our
relationship and
so what do you mean here what's the dot
dot dot i feel
i feel a shoe about to drop well there's
no
big shoe it's just before all of that
happened you know he was like i said the
love of my life
and even though things are so much
better now i'm
not as in love with him as i was before
and where he says like i'm the most in
love i've ever been in our relationship
and he's the happiest he's ever been in
our relationship
i'm not there yet because i still feel
like there's this
black mark there and the person that i
thought he was he
wasn't really because he was able to do
all of these extremely hurtful
things gotcha and so
you've you were hurt and so
here's one of the analogies i use we all
carry backpacks around
right and
let's assume and usually this isn't
fully accurate but let's just assume
here
that you had you played no role in
the affair things were perfect
you were the dream partner he was the
dream partner
and he just had a girlfriend for a year
and a half they just couldn't give up
fully
and if you think in those terms of the
backpack he picked up a cinder block and
just dropped it in your backpack
right he wrecked what you thought was
perfect
and you've been through therapy
you have recommitted yourself to one
another you've forgiven him
and for some reason you're still
carrying this around with you
tell me why you will not put that brick
down
because it's not weighing him down do
you have little kids too
yeah we have three little ones okay so
you got three little ones how old are
they
i have a seven-year-old a four-year-old
and a one-year-old
oh my gosh okay
on top of a pandemic too right because
why not
right in graduate school and why not
all right so why are you still holding
this brick
why are you still carrying it
i feel like some days i've let it go
you haven't some days you may take the
whole backpack off but for some reason
you're still carrying it why
i i'm up i think part of me is afraid
it'll happen again
can i tell you something that sucks it
might
yeah all relationships are risk
right and there's a part of your heart
and mind that was completely gutted when
this happened last time
and there's a part in your heart and
mind that is constantly vigilant for it
might happen again
right and that is a tiny little sliver a
tiny little fracture in your
relationship
that will be there until you fully
decide to put this brick down
and that means you're going to fully
risk getting hurt again
and it might happen again i hope it
never does but it might
but one thing you're you are for sure
making sure happens
is that you never fully give it a full
go because you're still hanging on to
that thing
and the only way to truly lean into this
deal
is if you put that brick down did it
hurt
yes was it your fault nope
did it happen yeah here's the other
thing
or leave right and it took me a long
time to
to accept the fact that i wasn't stuck
in this relationship by the time we
decided to stay together
and that i was choosing to stay right
for the first year
we were recovering i was resentful and
feel like i was tricked and and stuck in
this situation and
but i have moved past that but every
once in a while that
thought comes back so i want to back out
real quick and
give you this piece just as an outsider
okay
you have a seven a four and a one year
old you're in graduate school in the
middle of a pandemic
in a relatively new state
i want you to give yourself some grace
here okay
if you had the single greatest husband
who'd ever lived who was perfect and
only had eyes for you forever
things would still feel wonky and out of
place right now
things would still feel like a dumpster
fire because they are
okay and you put this on top of that
here's the thing if you said i forgive
you
there comes a moment and hear me
carefully okay
if you said i forgive you and i'm a
hundred percent in
have you all had another child y'all had
another baby since this huh
we did yes okay so you've you are so in
we made another human together
if you continue to carry this backpack
around
you are choosing to
injure the people in your home with it
does that make sense it does
how do i cause like i said there's a lot
and more and more there are days that i
don't have it and it tends to be the
days that i
am dealing with depression a little bit
more or maybe my anxiety pops up that
these thoughts come up more perfect i
don't really know how to
get it out at that point so have you
have you heard of me talk about
david kessler's work and the purple
elephant
uh is that just the the uh focusing your
mind
controlling your thoughts i guess there
you go so close your eyes real quick
you got it and i want you to imagine
all three of your kids standing on top
of one another outside in the front yard
you're one-year-old on the top of that
little kid pyramid
you got it and you see your one-year-old
up there with like a
yellow hat on and they're just waving in
the wind and you're afraid they're gonna
fall do you see them
yes okay open your eyes you just proved
to millions of people that you can
control your thoughts
you can't control what pops in there but
you can control what you choose to focus
on
and so the commitment you have to decide
is am i all in
if you are all in what you're going to
do over the next
few months over the next few years as
you continue to heal
is you're going to have to recognize
you're going to have to come to terms
with he could do this again
he probably won't let's hope let's give
him the benefit of the doubt my hope is
that you love him and know him enough
that
you would not have agreed to continue on
if if you really thought that was going
to happen
and then every time she pops into your
mind
you get to decide from that point
forward am i going to meditate on this
am i going to let it
set off all my alarms or am i going to
intentionally think of
a wonderful thing my husband's done
if every time that you wake up and
you're feeling anxious and you haven't
slept because you got a one-year-old and
you're exhausted and you're just eating
twinkies because they're so
good and your nutrition's low
and then you just all of a sudden are
struck with that day that he told you
hey we gotta talk and your stomach drops
and you get that warm feeling in your
stomach
that's the moment you get to decide nope
and in my house i actually say it out
loud
nope it's kind of become a joke with my
wife and my son my daughter doesn't
recognize it yet but i'll just be like
nope and that's just me announcing i'm
not gonna think about that
and now i've been doing it long enough
that literally it will go away
if an old crisis scene pops in my head
an old thing that i said to my wife an
old thing i did
um you know in the past pops into my
head i will go
nope and i will replace it with another
thought that's positive
because i get to make that choice and
you got to be
graceful with yourself because it's hard
and it takes time
right that uh grace for yourself is
it's a slow process
how much of this affair do you blame
yourself for
um i think at the beginning it was a lot
okay because during the time that it
happened i was
physically sick i was dealing with
postpartum depression from my
second and i was you know we were both
working full-time
jobs on opposite schedules and so i felt
like i wasn't
a good enough wife and partner and
blamed myself quite a bit
and and like i said
i did a lot a lot of therapy i was in
therapy like two or three times a week
sure for almost a year here's the part
well the kind of work done here's the
part that therapists often don't tell
you about okay
you have the initial shock that
devastating shock
of the affair but what they don't tell
you about is
you lose trust in yourself
yeah and you lose trust in how did i let
this
happen how did i not see this why am i
still with this guy what is wrong with
me
why am i having another kid with they
don't tell you that you lose trust in
yourself
and the person i want you to get
re-acquainted with
is you charlie because you are worth
treating yourself right
and the more you feel at home in your
own body
is the more you feel at home with this
guy
the more your brain will go all right
we're safe and by the way you just gave
me
a hint here was this about the age your
your second child was when you found out
he was yeah so he was about 15 months
when i found out
yeah so you're right smack in the middle
of it your brain is saying we remember
this we remember this watch out
right i didn't really think about that
oh my gosh i should have a podcast
i'm a genius you see that kelly genius
um
not really charlie not really charlie
but um
yeah so i wanna number one thank you so
much for the call
be kind to yourself love yourself let
your brain off the hook
and recognize that all relationship
starts with risk
people hurt one another they forgive one
another but if you've forgiven him
and you're choosing to continue to
weaponize this
then suddenly you're going to find
yourself becoming the offender in the
house
and that gap in that relationship is
going to affect your kids it's going to
affect your marriage
and so if you're all in be all in and
that means
risking pain sometime down the down the
way
and you're worth it tell your alarms
you're all right tell them thank you for
looking out for you but tell me all
right
all right let's take one more call let's
go to stephen in dallas my brother
stephen how are we doing
i'm doing well dr john how about
yourself doing good man man how can i
help
so my girlfriend and i have been dating
for about a year
um and in the beginning of our
relationship we gained some happy weight
and over the past few months we've been
what is happy weight
just going out to eat and cooking at
home and just
experiencing life during covet and stuff
like that eating probably more than we
should
okay um not working out okay and
stephen i'm just gonna tell you right
now i feel like you are setting me up
oh man i have a feeling i know this is
going man and you're already giving me
hives but go ahead
um and so we've been working out for the
past few months
and with how serious we're getting in
the stuff i have planned in the near
future
um the issue of our weight keeps coming
up in our conversations and it's really
kind of
pushing back the plans that we have
because it's creating a strain
um and i'm trying to figure out if you
could help me out figure out a way to
approach it
uh in a better way uh so we can grow our
relationship and get over this hurdle
oh stephen you are being very diplomatic
in your use of pronouns my man
you are saying our and we i need you
just to cut to the chase man
and i'm flinching for what i think
you're about to tell me but go for it
so i've gained about 25 pounds and i
ended up losing
10 pounds from where i started at so i
started at 220 and i'm down about 210
205.
after going up to 240 yes sir okay
and she has gained about 40 pounds
and is continually
doing her best to work out but
unfortunately it's not really helping
out
stephen are you calling me to ask
how you can tell your girlfriend
that she's gained weight no we've we've
had conversations
and to the point to where she wasn't
able to afford a gym membership and she
begged me to get one and i got her the
one that she wanted
um and for the past five months she's
gone nine times
and it's a hundred now it's 135 dollars
a month
and we even changed lifestyles like i
started grilling out took all the junk
food out i stopped drinking alcohol
because she said that's one thing she
wanted to do so i was like you know if i
want to make this happen and we want to
make this happen
she wants to make this happen i have to
set an example
of what you know needs to change and
unfortunately we're having a hard time
understanding each other in this moment
of what we need to do to move forward
and begin to
get to the process of where we want to
be with our physical appearance
oh man stephen there's so much here
and you know that we live in a cancel
culture right if i say the one wrong
thing here i'm done forever you realize
that right
i know and i don't want that to happen
you've just put a ball on a tee for me
and i'm also trying to be nice to you
because i kind of want to set you on
fire right now but that would be rude
and i'd go to jail okay so here's the
thing
i want to just kind of cut through
all of it okay you've got to let the
fantasy go
you are dating somebody who does not
share the same values as you
you are dating somebody who
is speaking the words that you want to
hear
but is making decisions for any number
of reasons
to live how she wants to live which is
different than a value you share
and for some reason you don't want to
see this
that she's not a math problem
and suddenly you're becoming her dad by
fixing her diet
and even the way you just said a month
tells me you got some rage underneath
there brother
yeah i mean it's kind of i have a
personal experience with this because in
higher
late high school or the college i
actually got up to 280 pounds
i know but here's the thing here's the
thing for you
it was a disciplined decision
and a moral decision and a character
issue
and you're assigning your character and
you're assigning your discipline
to somebody else who is not seeing it
that way
and no amount of male
assignment to a young woman is gonna
she's not gonna go oh that's the thing
that's what i ah that's it
thanks man i gained 40 or 50 pounds
because i just didn't know about x
and you changed all of my food and you
bought me a real expensive thing and you
got
angry and you sent me great discipline
and pinterest quotes
and you told me about your journey of
weight loss you lost 70 pounds which is
really impressive by the way
thank you that's what i was missing
thanks man
dude that's not how it's not going to
happen
so how do i change my my view set on
this
to i guess stephen you leave stop
hindering
steven you're getting all of the signals
you need
okay that's tough it's real tough
because uh just a few weeks ago i talked
to her parents about some stuff
yeah of course now i might have made an
investment
yeah you're in it brother
oh that's tough it is do you want to
leave her
no she's honest her character's above
approach everything you want
okay stephen okay stephen will you love
her
50 pounds heavier than you have her in a
picture in your mind
yes will you try to be a person who
co-creates a future with her and who
supports her and loves her and doesn't
try to father her
yes
then she's the one for you and i guess i
need to get over that superficial
mindset
hey hold on it's not about that it's not
about that because it's not bad to say
hey
who you were when we dated was 50 pounds
less if i showed up
50 pounds more to my wife right now that
would be a thing
and anyone who says different than that
is not telling the truth
but at 10 pounds at 20 pounds my wife
would come and sit down and say hey
you're not whole right now are you doing
okay
not hey we should have more fish and
chicken right
yeah and she would know me well enough
to know
that when i said something like i just
need to get some more kettle bells she
would say
no man john you go to the gummy candies
when you're not doing well when you're
stressed when you're anxious
right john you drink more than normal
wind
fill in the blank yeah and if i was
dating somebody
who was crushing it and trying to give
me
dietary tips and trying to
ask me why i wasn't using the expensive
gym membership they'd buy me
i'd drink more too dude
so i've just been i've been approaching
it completely wrong
um is that is that kind of where you're
getting that i'm getting it this
start treating her like she is a person
to be with
and a person to love and not a puzzle to
solve
she is not a malfunctioning
chevy engine that just needs to get the
uh you know
you know new headers or you know new
spark plugs yes sir
yes sir i understand she's dealing with
something in her heart
or she's not or she's not she may think
she's beautiful
and that things are great and she gets
to do that
yeah she does it it sounds like she's
told you
she doesn't like the trajectory of where
she's headed that she doesn't like
feeling unhealthy that she doesn't like
um
the decisions she's making which tells
me she's got underlying things
and again don't hear this everybody
listening and say because she put on
weight so you're such a jerk now that's
what i'm saying
i'm saying if somebody is saying
whatever the behavior is i'm out of
control and i can't stop
i've had several of these declarations
in my adult life about my addiction to
sugar
i got a problem dude like a bad problem
and there's been several times that i've
reached out to friends or to my wife and
said i
can't stop i have to not have sugar in
the house
for about a month and i gotta give away
my debit card
and my wife says cool i got you and her
and my kids will go to sonic
without me right they'll sneak and go
while i'm at work right
um but that's not about food
that's about something totally different
but i've also had seasons where i'm like
brother
it is dissertation time i'm writing a
book time i'm just gonna eat i'm gonna
enjoy my life i know i'm gonna pay for
it later but i'm gonna have fun with it
right
and those are two totally different
mindsets and so if she's not
loving the way she looks and she is
heartbroken
i want you to ask her where the
heartbreak comes from i want you to hold
her hands and say i'm not going to give
you any more advice
i'm just going to give you a safe place
to share
or if she says i'm really struggling
with
drinking too much then man that's not a
weight issue brother there's something
else going on
yeah she may be really nervous because
she knows you're about to ask her to
marry her
yeah she may be really nervous because
she is not totally sure about your
relationship
or she may just be really nervous
because 2020 sucks
yeah it sure does and she's in the
middle of a pandemic and
and work and whatever and whatever in a
partridge in a pear tree
all that to say is this i can hear in
your heart that you love this girl
and i can hear in your voice that you
are doing the best things that you know
how
and so on behalf of every guy across the
country i want to honor you trying to
love
her the best you can i also want to tell
you
that it's not working yeah and so i'm
going to ask you on behalf of every guy
in america
stop okay okay
from this point forward i want you to
ask permission to give advice when she
tells you something
i want you to say are you asking for my
input here
or you just want me to hear you okay
and she may fall over dead she may
absolutely pass out from that new
stephen right yeah for sure um and i
don't want you to beat yourself
up over shallowness and superficiality
right
50 pound weight gain in a year says
something's going on
yes sir okay something's going on right
whether it's physiological it's
biological it's psychological
something's going on there
right and that's not something that fish
and chicken's gonna solve
okay well i i appreciate all the input
you've given me well i appreciate you
being a guy that's
i'll tell you this when you're first
rattling this stuff off
i thought you were setting me up and
you're gonna get me fired and i was just
gonna say mean things to you
after hearing you i actually i really
believe that your heart's in the right
place
and you're really trying to do the best
you can and this is just a hard season
for everybody i would strongly recommend
that you and your wife go see
a premarital counselor if that's the
road you're taking
and you don't have to get engaged to do
that you could say hey i see us spending
some time together in the future
i want to learn ways that i can support
and love you better
and i'm a knucklehead i love my gym time
i love finding new discipline quotes
from jocko
i love finding new keto diet recipes
beefcake 2000 right but she doesn't
and you want to learn new ways to
communicate with her and support her and
love her better
to give her a safe place a peaceful
place
and if at the end of the day she chooses
man
i just have no interest in the the
physical health stuff that you're
interested in
i like to eat i like my body i think i'm
beautiful
then you have a choice to make but i
want you to start with listening
start with loving start with leaning
into the relationship part not to the
fish and chicken fix
here's a uh a new program and by the way
dude
when you invest money in somebody you
love and it doesn't work out
don't hold them hostage with it
she wanted to go to a really nice gym
she thought that's what it was going to
be
and then you did a cool thing a noble
thing you sprung for expensive gym
and then she probably walked in there
and saw all those super fit people and
all their super fancy
million dollar workout clothes and she
said nope i'm not going and i know too
many women who've had that exact
experience i know dudes who have
that experience so it is what it is
it's a sunk cost you learned
don't beat yourself up don't beat her up
over it it's expensive yeah
chalk it up man if she's the girl for
you over the next 50 or 60 years you'll
have plenty of those moments
and she's gonna buy you something fancy
and she's gonna miss the mark on that
too
just part of it right all right
so let's see
we're going to end this show up here
today let's end it with this song
this i didn't mean for it to to kind of
plug here
the way it did but we're going with it
from the greatest metal band
of all time the number one
heavy metal it's not actually it's just
a it's just
i think it's the greatest metal song of
all time off their 1992
vulgar display of power record pantera
dropped
the original groove core gem
walk and their lead singer philip
anselmo sings
he isn't really seeing but he's seeing
yells
can't you see i'm easily bothered by
persistence
one step from lashing out at you you
want in to get under my
skin and call yourself a friend i've got
more friends like you
what do i do is there no standard
anymore
what it takes who i am where i've been
where i belong
you can't be something you're not and be
yourself
by yourself stay away from me it's a
lesson
learned in life known from the dawn of
time
respect or walk what did you say
respect walk are you talking to me
are you talking to me walk on home boy
that'll boy walk on home boy this has
been the dr john deloney show
[Music]